on vit un moment tragique
vous le savez pour ceux qui n'était pas
là hier Cyril avait pris un pari si le
PSG
perdait il devait selon ses termes
déglinguer Daniel
le PSG a perdu
et beaucoup de questions se posent
puisque depuis hier soir on a ni revu
Daniel ni revu Cyril
alors que s'est-il passé cette nuit là
Daniel était enceinte
Daniel a tenu un orgasme
on continue un enfant si oui parce
qu'ils vont le garder et puis surtout
cette question
Cyril a-t-il bordé alors les amis
c'est une bonne question on a beaucoup
manqué Myriam palombas sera là avec
toutes les réponses si on m'avait dit un
jour que je recevrai bien un Palomba
pour un fait divers concernant Cyril et
puis moi si je suis là c'est que bien
sûr la chaîne avait besoin d'un
animateur et il y a que moi je vous
propose d'aller un recap de cette soirée
d'hier soir devant le match triste match
du PSG tragique pour Cyril et magique
pour Daniel à tout de suite
hier soir le PSG affronté le Bayern de
Munich en 8e de finale de la Ligue des
Champions l'occasion pour Cyril Hanouna
de faire une petite promesse si le PSG
ne se qualifie pas ce soir je déglingue
Daniel et pour assister au match
l'animateur de TPMP avait donné
rendez-vous au chroniqueur chez lui mais
très vite le match à vireau fiasco pour
les coéquipiers de Kylian Mbappé
un but puis de le PSG c'est finalement
incliné a été éliminé de la compétition
pour le plus grand bonheur de Daniel
Moreau
alors que s'est-il passé hier lors de
l'après match Bayern - PSG entre Cyril
et Daniel Moreau Myriam balomba nous dit
tout ce soir dans TPMP
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous merci à vous de m'avoir invité j'ai
posé une question très simple que
s'est-il passé cette nuit
claire la plus précise possible parce
que les faits sont assez graves donc à
21h13 à peu près tous les chroniqueurs
ont décidé de se rendre à la sortie du
studio pour prendre un van et
aller dans le domaine de Cyril Hanouna
c'est va donc
donc là ils prennent tout ce van et puis
comme c'est pas très loin d'ici vers
21h25 ils arrivent tous dans le domaine
là ils sont ravis parce qu'il y a des
majeurs d'hommes qui les accueillent
avec des petits fours
avec des petits fous des du champagne il
y a même des jambons de la mer que nous
on connaît sous l'appellation souris
Miki qui est là et qui sont là et jusque
là tout va bien jusque là tout va bien
même l'ambiance elle est elle est plutôt
bonne à l'ambiance elle est même très
bonne Cyril cyril est détendu il croit
vraiment à la victoire du PSG les
chroniqueurs aussi enfin tout va bien
c'est c'est plutôt sympathique
l'ambiance moi qu'on m'a décrite elle
est plutôt chic et classe et puis
Jordan qui font que ces chiens donc tout
le monde est là tout le monde est là
et moi selon mes informations et et je
vais utiliser le conditionnel parce que
c'est des chroniqueurs anonymes qui
m'ont apporté cette information
visiblement
visiblement Daniel Moreau aurait sursuré
à l'oreille de Cyril ce soir ton ballon
va finir dans ma culotte
désolé pour le PSG les chroniqueurs
j'imagine s'en vont la nuit démarre et
c'est ce qu'on veut savoir qu'est-ce qui
se passe totalement précise que vous
dites la Matthieu précisément ce qui se
passe c'est que
Cyril là il est un peu effrayé on va pas
se mentir
il se met dans son canapé très classe il
essaie de se protéger comme il peut avec
les avec les coussins et puis et puis à
la fin du match bah là c'est le drame
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment durable
Daniel Moreau aurait demandé j'insiste
sur le conditionnel parce que
visiblement c'est très important
Daniel Moreau aurait demandé des
relations sexuelles non conventionnelles
[Rires]
c'est pas grave ça c'est très très grave
donc du coup ma question ne marche plus
parce que ma question était pensez-vous
que scientifiquement aujourd'hui avec
l'avancée de la science Daniel puisse
être enceinte mais si c'est non
conventionnel j'ai un doute là ça me
paraît compliqué
mais du coup elle a dormi là-bas elle
est partie ce matin
la suite c'est qu'elle elle lui a
demandé en fait elle se serait jetée sur
lui alors c'est ce que des chroniqueurs
anonymes je le répète m'ont dit
visiblement visiblement elle s'est jetée
sur lui la soulevé et là attention je
sais pas si je peux le dire avec genre
je sais pas si je peux le dire
vous pouvez tout dire la collision
[Applaudissements]
je suis en FaceTime avec mon ami mon
frère
c'est je l'aime Gad Elmaleh qui regarde
l'émission il est avec son fils que
j'aime aussi et son fils m'a dit Cyril
quand est-ce que tu rentres le plateau
ils sont un peu saoulant
tu vois je t'ai pas menti je t'ai pas
menti frérot dis à ton fils que tout est
rentré dans l'ordre je suis sur le
plateau il va pouvoir regarder
l'émission gentiment d'accord mon frère
mais c'est dégueulasse c'est dégueulasse
qui le disent c'est dégueulasse que tu
me le dises à l'antenne
s'il vous plaît
[Rires]
sur le sable les yeux dans l'eau je te
jure frère
je t'aime frère je t'aime mon frère je
t'aime rester là et pour toi Mathieu je
t'aime mon frère
c'est gentil mais non mais c'est pour
elle ah bon
[Musique]
quand tes pensées que rien
de beau ne m'échappe à part toi
seul quelques silences
car quand je dors
je n'ai plus de raison
[Musique]
si je me détruit
je fais le tour de tes mots des
promesses et des Ovide ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je me tais oui
d'être pour toi
l'hélicoptère tu dessines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
er
[Musique]
l'âme n'est pas la question
je n'attends rien
de tes yeux tes efforts j'ai
pris le
feu a ton corps
[Musique]
si je me
détruit
je fais le tour de tes mots tes
promesses et des envies d'ailleurs
[Musique]
et tant pis
être pour toi
[Musique]
tu désires
c'est pour toi c'est bon
ce matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ton cœur n'ose pas
[Musique]
si je me
je fais le tour de tes bonnes blessé des
envies d'ailleurs
tant pis ce sera plus jamais comme avant
d'être pour toi
[Musique]
reste plus
malgré mes blessures
[Applaudissements]
plein de bisous
[Musique]
ah j'ai envie de chicoter
beaucoup plus de but que le PSG
[Applaudissements]
c'est un animal voilà même chez lui-même
dans sa chambre je me suis dit qu'il
mettait dans le mille à tous les coups
donc j'ai quand même voulu vérifier ce
matin et donc Myriam vous aimez les
SCOOP j'en ai un ça y est le petit est
en route
[Applaudissements]
chérie quel bonheur quel bonheur c'est
triplés
familiales hier je t'envoie des petits
textos pour rigoler alors c'est rigoler
c'est rigolait c'est rigoler ça du match
c'est 2-0 et là genre bonne chance il y
a plus de réponse
je vous dis la vérité et j'ai découvert
un truc hier soir que je ne savais pas
il est aussi
insupportable dans la vie qu'à l'écran
c'est Gilles Verdez
[Rires]
ta meuf se mariera jamais avec quoi
frère je te le dis tu es parti je suis
resté avec Benaim je lui ai dit mais
c'est un truc de ouf vous m'avez pas
retenu quand je suis parti
je me suis en fait c'est quand il suit
les sorts du plateau que tu te rends
compte qu'ils sont vraiment très dieuses
de ma mère j'ai compris j'ai dit j'ai
une bande de vieiro à la maison mais de
ouf mon frère et l'autre Castaldi il
comprend
tu comprends rien toute la région
que lui il avait des chaussures mon
frère un enfer mais sans rien et ses
chaussures elles marchent devant lui il
est obligé de sucer les chaussures le
gars ces chaussures marche plus vite que
lui c'est un enfer sur la tête de ma
mère il était éclaté au sous-sol vers le
gars il est pris une chaise pliante
maintenant
gilbertez un enfer mais quoi un enfer
j'ai jamais vu un enfer comme ça voilà
je te le dis pardon Cyril c'était quoi
la présence d'une chroniqueuse qu'on ne
connaît pas
de la famille
et non non voilà et quand elle vient à
Paris elle vient souvent me voir comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
sortie du numéro 14 Daniel Moreau entrée
du numéro 7 Clara Morgane
ça vous arrivera c'est marrant parce que
comme il y a deux mois vous avez
expliqué l'amitié fille garçon ça
existait pas elle est mariée
voilà forcément et puis on était on se
connaît depuis des années un moment que
je peux vous dire
c'est la famille c'est la famille mettez
la photo
marine voilà
existence non mais
c'est vrai que ça fait pas jeune boite
faudrait prendre que ça en fait
[Rires]
c'est la dernière photo avant sa mort
je suis parti avant la fin du match vous
savez que je l'entendais gueuler à 50 m
de chez vous
à 50 mètres de chez moi c'est toujours
chez moi
[Applaudissements]
on est encore bientôt il y aura un piège
Cyril 10 km je me suis dit oui c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est le travail et puis le
travail chez vous c'est bizarre je vous
ai baigné ça m'a fait plaisir ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
pour un maillot de bain
c'est pour que tu passes pour un con
surtout non non ils sont restés ils sont
restés dans le salon gentiment et après
ils sont rentré je vous dis la vérité
dans le salon très gentil
[Rires]
ible
j'ai une question foot la pelouse était
bien tendue
c'est un grand oui
parce que je trouve que même le votre
temps à changer un autre homme
aujourd'hui
préliminaire
[Rires]
déjà je vous dis la vérité j'ai tout
délavé au sécateur
s
sur le terrain mais il y en a eu un dans
ma culotte voilà je résume
[Rires]
et quand vous y entrez difficile d'en
sortir
quand vous touchez le soleil
bravo ma chérie bravo dans un instant